-Guys, it is time for "Tonight
Show Hashtags." Here we go.
-♪ Hashtags ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Now, since today is 4/20,
I sent out a hashtag,
#StonerThoughts.
And I asked you to respond with
some funny or weird thoughts
that you might have had
when you were high.
Within minutes, it was
a trending topic in the U.S.
I don't know why.
[ Cheers and applause ]
But thank you all
for playing along.
So right now,
I'd like to share
some of my favorite
stoner thoughts from you guys.
Okay, here we go.
This first one is from
@elise millsssss.
-Wow.
-They say...
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Mind blown!
-Or sucked.
-Right.
-Mind blown.
-Or sucked.
-That's correct.
This one's from @--
Oh, I see -- @C0NN3XXX10N.
-Oh, nice.
-C-0-N-N-3-X-X-X-10-N.
-Nice.
-C0NN3XXX10N.
-Yeah.
Ready for this one?
-It's going to bl--
suck my mind.
[ Laughter ]
They say...
♪♪
-Whoa! Whoa!
Nice!
[ Imitates psychedelic rock ]
Should we do like that?
Like, a little Phish jam
at the end of that?
-Yes.
-Alright, good.
-Yeah, every one.
-This one's from
@LongHairedGuy31.
-Who would think
he'd be a stoner?
[ Laughter ]
-He says...
[ Psychedelic rock playing ]
[ Imitates psychedelic rock ]
-Doing, like,
a little bolero there.
-Yeah. A little Ravel in there.
This is from @minnice.
-Minnice.
-He says...
[ Psychedelic rock playing ]
-[ Imitates psychedelic rock ]
-[ Imitates water bubbling ]
[ Exhales deeply ]
-This one...
[ Laughter ]
-That was old school.
-This one is from @MrFunkyBeef.
-Dang!
-Ooh!
-Oh! Hit me one time.
♪♪
Hit me two times.
-Mr. Funky Beef!
-Ladies and gentlemen...
-Coming to the stage,
live from his tour...
-[ Imitates psychedelic rock ]
Alright, this one from
MrFunkyBeef.
-Oh, dude,
that's some funky beef.
-He says...
[ Psychedelic rock playing ]
Smile, dude.
Ooh, this one's interesting.
This one's from @BluddyHolli.
-Ooh, BluddyHolli.
Like Buddy Holly, but bloody?
Yeah.
-Damn.
-She says...
[ Psychedelic rock playing ]
I don't know why
that's anything, but --
-Yeah, but it's true.
-It's true.
The more I read it -- the more
I read it today, I was like --
-I've never seen a baby pigeon
and I've never seen a microwave.
-This one's from
@RyanBartholomee.
He says...
-Ooh!
[ Psychedelic rock playing ]
-Okay, this is a good last one.
Here we go.
This one's from @Atrvs451.
They say...
There you have it.
Those are our
"Tonight Show Hashtags."
To check out more
of our favorites,
go to
tonightshow.com/hashtags.